وهذا الكلام انا بوجهه خصوصا لجلن وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي وبوجهه لنتنياهو
شخصيا شخصيا نتنياهو وجنت بحملهم
المسؤوليه شخصيا عن ابناء عن قتل ابنائي
الاطفال وعن قتل زوجتي وعمتهم
والشاب البريء وسيم الذي ليس له علاقه باي
تنظيم من التنظيمات سواء من قريب او من
بعيد والله المنتقم الجبار وانتم تقولون
تقولون هل تخلى عننا رب موسى وهارون نعم
سيتخلى عنكم لانكم مشركين ومجرمين ولا
يرضى الاجرام الله الذي تقولون رب موسى
وهارون لا يرضى هذا الاجرام لا يرضى ان
تخرجون من بيوتنا وتقتلون هكذا مثل
الحيوانات تتعاملون معنا لا انتم
الحيوانات ليس نحن نحن بني ادمين لدينا
مشاعر ولدينا احساس ولدينا ولدينا دم لكن
انتم انتم مجردين من كل احسب
ومن كل مشاعر ومن كل دم انتم حيوانات
بشريه لا تستحقوا الحياه لا تستحقوا
الحياه مجرمين تقتلون بطش في النساء تشون
بالاطفال والنساء وانتم قادرين قادرين ان
تستهدف اللي بدكم اياه تستهدفه بطلاق واحد
مش
بصاروخ مش بصاروخ تقتل الاطفال والابرياء
النايمين
مظلومين انا ادعو الله سبحانه وتعالى ادعو
الله سبحانه وتعالى ان ان يحصل في ابنائكم
ليس فيكم في ابنائكم وزوجاتكم كما حصل في
ابنائنا وزوجاتنا ليس فيكم انتم تشاهدونه
وتتحسر عليهم كما نتحسر على ابنائنا
وزوجاتنا
وشهداءنا